do you have magic hair no magic hands
no do animals talk to you if you've ever
dreamed of being a disney princess
you might be reconsidering when you
realize how much time they spend trapped
in various places
don't worry you don't need a prince to
rescue you because our favorite
princesses have taught us how to have
fun
even if we're feeling a little bit
claustrophobic let's see how they spend
time when going out is not an option
yeah i don't think so rapunzel may be a
princess
but we know she's really the queen of
quarantine
going 18 years without a haircut is
rough and even if your hair isn't as
long as rapunzel's it can be rough when
you go
too long between trims take this time to
pamper your hair
with a deep conditioning treatment if
going to a hair salon
isn't an option spending time on your
hair can be a great way to spend your
days and relax
and if you don't already have one this
could be the perfect time to adopt or
foster an animal in need you've got to
be
kidding me if you can't invite your
friends over to build the snowman
or do anything else don't fret because
this could be a great opportunity to
improve your living space
it can be difficult to resist hitting
this snooze button in the morning but
sticking to a schedule can make the days
feel like they're going by faster
wake up wake up anna knows the
importance of being an early riser
and while we don't recommend talking to
the artwork this could be a great chance
to rearrange your decor
take this opportunity to go marie condo
on your living space
since your environment can have a big
impact on your mood
it can be tempting to scroll through
tiktok all day but going wireless can be
a great chance to reconnect with the
people you live with
when was the last time your family got
together for a good old-fashioned game
of charades
unredeemable monster greatest mistake of
your life we didn't even kiss you
you don't have to get quite as personal
as the frozen crew and if charades
aren't your thing there are plenty of
great board games out there to choose
from
but in the interest of maintaining
harmony in your household it
might be a good idea to skip monopoly
ariel couldn't wait to leave the ocean
behind in favor of dry land but moana
was the complete opposite
before she could take off on her
incredible journey she had to learn
about her family's history
and that can be a great way to pass the
time you've been told
all our people's stories but
one you don't have to splurge for a
23andme
just call some of your family members
and ask them questions about their lives
and see what stories they have to share
about the past
you never know what interesting tales
you may uncover and this can also be a
good chance to get closer with your
family
although this could end up inspiring you
to sail far
far away if you're working from home you
might enjoy getting a break from your
normal work clothes
should you find yourself with some extra
free time take a note from merida
and practice a hobby archery might not
be an option for everyone but there are
plenty of other ways to pass the time
if your current talents don't translate
well to staying at home this could be a
great chance to learn a new skill
there's a youtube tutorial for pretty
much everything nowadays so if you're
caught up on the latest content from the
things
why not learn how to draw learn another
language or just learn the art of
properly applying highlighter
prince naveen didn't start broadening
his horizons until he was turned into a
frog but you don't need to wait for that
you know i i i've never done anything
like this before
really have you ever wished you could
cook a gumbo like tiana whether you're a
frozen dinner kind of princess
or a great cook there's always something
new you can learn in the kitchen
if you love cooking already work on
perfecting your favorite recipe
or try a completely new kind of cuisine
than you're used to cooking
if you're more of a novice don't worry
if you work hard like tiana
you can learn to make an impressive meal
before we met rapunzel
and tangled jasmine was one of the most
isolated disney princesses out there
although she did have a pet tiger to
hang out with she learned the hard way
that going out shopping isn't always a
good idea
especially when you're a little bit
light on cash you'd better be able to
pay for that pay many stores now let you
shop online and pick up your goods
curbside
so if you can't make it to the mall this
is a great option
just remember to watch your budget
unless you're as rich as a princess
we disagree with gaston on a lot of
things
from how many eggs is advisable to eat
in a single day to this
it's not right for a woman to read soon
she starts getting ideas
and thinking many disney movies involve
beautiful castles gorgeous gowns and
romance
but can we take a moment to appreciate
val's library
talk about life goals you don't need a
giant library to lose yourself in a good
book
so get started on those novels you've
been meaning to read if you prefer a
good audio book
many libraries allow you to download
them without even having to leave the
house
we bet belle wishes she had that option
honestly when you're stuck at home with
nowhere to go it can be tempting to
start sleeping your time away
but don't forget that princess aurora
didn't exactly take that long nap on
purpose
before her curse came into play she
enjoyed spending time outside in nature
even if you don't go anywhere spending
some time in your backyard can be
relaxing you might find a whole new
appreciation for your living
space and maybe some feathered friends
while you're at it i'm really not
supposed to speak to strangers
but we've met before poor cinderella was
so tired of being at home
that even putting on a pair of glass
slippers was preferable to scrubbing the
floors yet again
seriously how were those comfortable no
wonder she lost one of them
but getting glammed up isn't necessarily
a bad idea in fact
it can feel good to get dressed up even
if you don't have anywhere to go
when you're in a rush to get out the
door trying out a new look can be a
gamble
so take advantage of the opportunity to
attempt that intimidating makeup
tutorial
it would be easier if we all had a fairy
godmother to wave a wand
but in light of that try putting on
something that makes you
feel fabulous beautiful dress
did you ever see such a beautiful dress
if you're handy in the kitchen then you
probably know that cooking and baking
are two entirely different things baking
requires a ton of precision
and sometimes a sprinkle of pixie dust
can make or break a dish
we don't recommend having animals in
your kitchen like snow white does but
baking can be a fun way to pass the time
and as a bonus your house will smell
amazing
making yes gooseberry pie
fans of the little mermaid know ariel
has a fine appreciation for
art it looks just like him it even has
his eyes
filling your room ceiling to floor with
stuff is frowned upon here on the
surface
but if you've got a hankering to feast
your eyes on some art like ariel
we have a solution many museums are
offering online tours you can access
from the comfort of your own home
true it's not quite the same as an
in-person visit but it's a lot easier
and doesn't require making a deal with a
sea witch
the louvre offers free online tours of
some of its most popular exhibits
or you can take a look at the
smithsonian national museum of natural
history
just to name a couple of options if
you're not a big art fan
and painting with the colors of the wind
isn't an option don't worry
you might not be able to sing as well as
pocahontas but when you're at home you
can really sing like no one is listening
you can practice your pitch or just have
fun singing along to your favorite songs
youtube has tons of disney sing-along
tracks that show the lyrics along with
the music
although we have a feeling you know most
of the classics by heart
i once had a dream that i might wear a
shirt
we don't need an excuse to listen to our
favorite disney songs but they do help
drown out the urge to make drastic
hairstyle changes
while that's always an option just think
carefully before you grab the scissors
and definitely don't use a sword like
mulan did but if you cut your hair short
it can make it easier to keep it out of
your face when you exercise
which is a wonderful way to spend time
if you can't get to a gym
there are tons of excellent at-home
workouts available
you don't have to have fancy equipment
or be as swift as a coursing river to
get those endorphins flowing
which of these disney princesses do you
relate to the most tell us your pick in
the comment section below and make sure
to click on the subscribe button and
turn on your notifications to stay
connected with us here at the things
bye for now
you